a lot of group
a tough bunch of people right and I want
to thank you Melania you've been really
the talk of Japan they're not covering
me I'm a little bit upset with her right
now
now they love you in Japan honey and we
appreciate it very much really works
very hard they love our first lady and
they love our first lady back home I
want to just tell everyone before we
even begin at ease that it's just
realized we have plenty of time plenty
of time we're gonna have a little fun
and I'm thrilled to be aboard the USS
Wasp with the brave sailors and Marines
the seventh Fleet special special people
thank you very much great job thank you
[Applause]
and I have to wish you all a very happy
Memorial Day right
Memorial Day very special back home and
I always like to be back in the US as
you do for that day but we did a lot of
great things for the last three days in
Japan so we're working together you're
working I'm working we're all working
together as president I have no higher
honor than serving as your
commander-in-chief and the extraordinary
men and women of the American armed
forces this has been a truly amazing and
unforgettable visit to Japan Milani and
I are profoundly grateful to their
Majesties the new Emperor and Empress at
the great honor of being their first
state guests that was a big honor for
our country we're also deeply thankful
to our cherished friends and treasured
partners Prime Minister and mrs. a be
very very great people our thanks as
well to ambassador Haggerty and his wife
Chrissy thank you very much thank you
ma'am bastard Thank You Chrissy thank
you very much great job you doing today
we're proud to be joined by the many
outstanding military leaders
we have a lot these are very incredible
ones I especially want to thank
commanding officer of USS Wasp Captain
Christopher her
[Applause]
they like you Christopher they like you
a lot
that's very good Christopher and the
command master chief
Kevin guy
[Applause]
popular people
[Applause]
Wow great leaders my thanks as well to
Lieutenant General Kevin Schneider
commander of the US forces Japan thank
you
[Applause]
vice-admiral Phil Sawyer commander of
the u.s. seventh Fleet
[Applause]
and you know they're all such good
looking people you have all this media
over here they can end up in Hollywood
they gonna leave us some of them will be
picked for Hollywood right and they and
they won't do it they like this better
and I agree Rear Admiral Gregory Fenton
commander of the United States naval
force Japan
thank you thank you thank you Rear
Admiral James Pitts commander of the
submarine group seven
[Applause]
and you know we're doing a lot of big
submarines right now we're building a
lot of them I'll tell you the best in
the world not even a contest right
it's really something I just saw plans
for one well that they're no longer the
little submarines that we think about
these are incredible machines right
thank you very much
Brigadier General Tardos you're deputy
commander of the 5th Air Force Todd
thank you
[Applause]
Rear Admiral Fred Kocher commander of
task force 76 thank you very much thank
you very much great leaders Captain Jim
McGovern commander of the amphibious
squadron 11 and Captain Jeffrey Kim
commander of Fleet activities right here
thank you very much
[Applause]
together these officers are leading the
most fearsome group of American warriors
this side of the Pacific we have more
than 1,000 sailors and Marines from the
seventh Fleet here today including
hundreds who serve on this impressive
assault ship USS Wasp also joining us
are sailors from the following ships USS
Shiloh USS Chancellorsville USS mustin
USS Barry loved those ships USS
McCampbell USS Benford Thank You fellas
that's great great pride finally I want
to recognize our many shore base
commands here today including large
contingents from Navy Region Japan thank
you very much
we like the fleet anti-terrorism
security team the Naval Intelligence
operation center fleet logistics center
Yokosuka the ship repair facility I'll
bet you guys do a good job do they do a
good job with the ships prepare it
[Applause]
so then let me ask you a question
catapult right the catapult system
do you like electric or steam steam who
said electric there's one guy back there
okay I really need this information
because you know we're building carriers
we're building one they're using an
electric catapult and an electric
elevator number one I can't imagine in
the case of battle it must be very
delicate okay and you know steams only
worked for about 65 years perfectly and
I won't tell you this because it's
before my time by a little bit but they
have a nine hundred million dollar cost
overrun on this crazy electric catapult
I said what was wrong with steam I would
like to know all of the folks that know
exactly what I'm talking about the
catapult system steam or electric ready
steam electric
he works for the enemy a czar I will do
you might be in danger I better begin
now we want to go it seemed you know
they're always coming who idea x'
they're making plane so complex you
can't fly him you know that no it's they
want to show next next next and we all
want innovation but it's too much but
there's never been anything like the
steam catapults and I went to the Gerald
Ford which is under construction now for
a long time they having a problem with
their electric catapult and I was
talking to the catapult people when they
said steam in the meantime we're
spending all that money on electric and
nobody knows what its gonna be like in
bad conditions you understand so I think
I'm gonna put an order when we build a
new aircraft cannon carrier we're gonna
use steam I'm gonna just put out an
order we're gonna use steam we don't
need we don't need that extra speed you
know they were saying one of the folks
said no the the electric works faster
but Sir we can only get the plane there
every couple of minutes so really what
they did was wrong and we make mistakes
but generally speaking we get it right
but when we make them we have to corrupt
him so we're gonna put out an order we
want to use steam the military doctors
and nurses from the US Naval Hospital
Yokosuka and many more so many people so
many great great people every marine and
sailor standing on USS Wasp is the face
of American strength and power in the
Pacific the 7th fleet is America's
largest forward deployed naval fleet
together you are 70 ships and submarines
strong with 140 aircraft and 40,000 of
America's finest sailors and Marines did
you know that about yourselves not bad
it's very impressive with us today is
Marine Staff Sergeant Daniel Patterson
wizz Daniel where's Daniel get over here
Daniel
[Applause]
tough-looking guy every single
generation of Staff Sergeant Patterson's
family has served in the United States
military all the way back to the
Revolutionary War but Staff Sergeant
Patterson was the first to choose the
Marines after completing two tours of
duty in Afghanistan staff sergeant
Patterson requested another overseas
tour this time wanted to go to Japan
he knows that American needs and what
they need is daring and mighty warriors
in the Pacific and he's a daring and
mighty warrior Staff Sergeant Patterson
today you and your fellow Marines and
sailors seventh Fleet are confronting
this region's pressing security
challenges with unmatched courage and
valor you know what's going on you know
where we're talking you know what we're
talking about we really appreciate your
being here Daniel I'm going to do
something that you didn't expect say a
few words Daniel
they will it's uh it's such a privilege
to be here with you mr. president and I
definitely expect this and it's an honor
and privilege to serve with my fellow
sailors and Marines and drive our
mission forward that general Smith in
the Komondor and chroma Brody is Kara
laid out for us we know why we're here
and we know what we need who we need to
aggress because if we don't we ourselves
just sleep on it for even a second then
we won't be the ultimate power in the
world so thank you very much and thank
all of you
[Applause]
good job you'll be running for political
office within two weeks look Daniel
great everyday the men and women of the
seventh fleet live out their motto ready
power for peace you face down terrorism
and render aid in the wake of
devastating natural disasters and I've
seen what you do incredible you proudly
patrol the Yellow Sea the Sea of Japan
the East China Sea and the South China
Sea you defend your homeland and our
allies against missile attack with our
most advanced radar and weapon systems
in the world we have equipment missiles
rockets tanks planes ships nobody in the
entire world can build them like we do
nobody it's not even close you know that
better than anybody here in the Pacific
and around the globe we want our armed
forces to have the tools resources and
equipment you need and that you deserve
that's why we have given our 7th fleet
new american-made f-35b marine fighter
aircraft very stealthy you know that
right
the enemy has a problem with it you know
what the problem is they can't see it
other than that it's a fair fight
just like my one and this one right here
that just came out beautiful last year
USS Wasp
made history when it became the very
first ship to deploy these cutting-edge
aircraft I want to congratulate you all
and you're getting a lot of brand-new
ones we're getting brand-new equipment
you know when I came two and a half
years ago we had planes that were so old
they didn't make parts for them anymore
you don't have that anymore you don't
have that we're getting all new
beautiful equipment we need it we need a
peace through strength right
in April USS Wasp also became the first
ship to deploy f-35 bees in the Bali
Canton
naval exercise with the Philippines and
with Australia later this year the USS
Wasp returns home we will be sending the
men and women of the seventh Fleet our
most formidable amphibious assault ship
USS America USS America will soon be
sailing these Pacific waters and I'm
pleased to say that she will also be
carrying the most beautiful f-35 B's on
her deck brand-new brand-new my
administration is committed to ensuring
that America's military strength forever
remains second to none over the past two
years we have made historic investments
in our military with seven hundred
billion dollars right general that's
billions right
no more millions not when it comes to
our military it's a little bit scary
with the be scary you know used to be
millions now it's billions and that's
the way it has to be because we have to
protect our country we have to protect
our allies and last year 716 billion
dollars so this year we're going up and
in a very short period of time our
military will be completely rebuilt and
stronger bigger better than ever before
won't even be close and we're very close
and when I took over we were very
depleted and you people knew that better
than anybody we would deplete it it's
the only word I can use to describe it
it was not a good situation but we're
gonna be very close right now we're very
close very shortly we're going to be at
a level the likes of which we've never
been before this includes money for five
new guided missile destroyers four new
nuclear-powered fast attack submarines
that's so when you want okay we got we
got four of them you only wanted one we
got you four and a hundred and
sixty-three brand-new f-35 Joint Strike
Fighter
Jetts as Prime Minister Abbey and I
discussed yesterday Japan also plans to
equip the Japanese self-defense forces
with a hundred and five f-35 aircraft
which would make Japan's f-35 fleet the
largest of any US ally the us-japan
alliance has never been stronger the
relationship between your president and
the prime minister of japan it's great
gentlemen great man is a fantastic one
this remarkable port is the only one in
the world where we're American naval
fleet and an allied naval fleet
headquartered side-by-side a testament
to the ironclad partnership between US
and Japanese forces together you're
advancing freedom on the high seas
shielding our nation from dangerous
weapons and preserving the peace that
generations of valiant American warriors
gave their lives to secure one of those
intrepid Americans was private first
class John Shaffer born and raised in
Tower City Pennsylvania private Schaffer
was a member of a group of US Army
Special Forces who fought in the Pacific
during World War two under the legendary
command of General Frank Merrill good
general the general pretty good right
that's what they say are you better just
be as good although private Shaffer
sadly perished in the Battle of Burma
his deep love of country indoors and
someone very special with us today his
grandnephew senior chief petty officer
Daniel Shafer where's Daniel
[Applause]
and I want to thank you very much for
the incredible job you've done
we picked a couple of people that are
outstanding please say a couple of words
Thank You mr. president this is amazing
do you recognize my family but I know a
lot of others have families that served
as well Memorial Day is that time where
we honor our fellow Americans who paid
the ultimate sacrifice sacrifice so you
know thank you for all my shipmates and
fellow Marines that are out here today
it's a great day
Thank You mr. president
[Applause]
[Applause]
two great jobs and that's not easy they
don't know they're coming up you didn't
know did you
you had no idea and you both did it they
didn't choke we don't like chokers do we
we don't like we don't like chokers on
this Memorial Day in the United States
Americans are concluding a sacred day of
remembrance reflection and prayer
citizens all across the country came
together to decorate the graves of our
fallen heroes and to honor their
selfless acts of courage the citizens of
our country are incredible they love our
country and they love you they love you
you have no idea how much they love you
down through history from America's
earliest days fearless Americans have
said goodbye to their loved ones gone
off to war and stared down our enemies
knowing that they may never ever return
Memorial Day links every grateful
American heart in eternal tribute to
those brave souls who gave their last
breath for our nation from Concord to
Gettysburg from Midway to Mosul today
the unbreakable resolve of these heroes
lives on in every American who wears our
great uniform each day that you serve on
these rolling but beautiful seas you
honor their sacrifice you carry on their
righteous duty and you continue their
noble legacy our Republic indoors
because of brave men and women who are
willing to lay down their lives to
defend us all our freedom has earned
through the blood and sweat and toil and
sacrifice of great American patriots
just like you as we honor America's
fallen warriors we pledge our unwavering
devotion
all of those who serve our nation in
uniform throughout this region from
Yogesh to Guam to Singapore to Okinawa
to Bush on the seventh Fleet is holding
the line and defending the peace among
the sailors and Marines the USS Wasp you
Service Warfare Officers naval aviators
marine riflemen air crewmen corpsman
machinist mates avionics to go ahead you
can do it
ordnance technicians ok where are the
avionics guys and gals right there good
that's complicated business right got to
be pretty good cooks fire control men
and women intelligence specialists or
the intelligence special good great
great you know that great nurses and
engineers nearly nearly every specialty
in our seventh Fleet is represented on
the ship today you are the strongest
toughest best and bravest do you agree
with it you better you are the ones keep
going and striving and keeping America
safe and strong and proud and free you
defend our freedom our families and you
defend our great American flag
[Applause]
you showed the world the force of
American might an American heart and you
prove across these perilous waters and
far beyond that there is no match on
earth for the awesome power and glory of
the American Navy and the United States
Marines to the men and women of America
seventh Fleet the First Lady and I have
been to be with you all today on behalf
of all Americans we thank you we salute
you we honor you we cherish you and we
stand with you now and forever
thank you to the proud sailors and
Marines of USS Wasp god bless you god
bless our military and god bless the
United States of America thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]